[Music]
no doubt you've seen the chaos in the
streets
we must make an example where France
will fall
what would you do if this assignment of
defense was transferred to you
[Applause]
[Music]
I promise you probably had successes
everyone
around
what does this costume you have all this
is my uniform
I love the French Factory too long
what is your name Napoleon that's the
course of my life just changed Napoleon
[Applause]
I'm destined for greatness
but I was in power only see me as a
sword
I suggest you take the throne as a king
shall we vote
this learning has held the world hostage
with his egotism and his lack of simple
good manners
I'm great
there is nothing without me
of Europe is United forces against me
what's the outcome of this you don't
succeed
Your Majesty we are discovered good
first to admit when I make a mistake
I simply never do
foreign